欸，你聽過日本長野縣的野澤溫泉滑雪度假村嗎？他們最近做了一個挺出乎意料的決定，我覺得很有意思。
野澤溫泉？我有點印象，好像是個挺受外國遊客歡迎的地方。怎麼，他們是要蓋什麼超豪華飯店，還是擴大滑雪場規模？
都不是。他們反而是限制高樓飯店的開發。當地政府希望吸引那些有長期眼光的投資者，而不是只追求短期回報的快速開發案。
限制開發？這有點弔詭吧。現在觀光業不是都恨不得多蓋幾間飯店，多賺點錢嗎？尤其像野澤溫泉這種觀光熱點，需求應該很強勁啊。
對啊，這就是讓人詫異的地方。報導提到，因為強勁的入境旅遊需求，的確有很多飯店開發案想進駐。但野澤溫泉的市政當局，反而決定要限制這些大型物業開發。
等等，這裡我有疑問。他們具體怎麼限制的？是直接說不准蓋，還是有什麼容積率、高度限制？這樣會不會把潛在的投資者都嚇跑啊？
報導裡沒提到具體的數字或規範，只說「限制大型物業開發」，而且是針對「專注於短期回報的投資」。我猜啦，可能是透過一些建築法規或土地使用條例來引導。
嗯，這點其實不容易做到。畢竟那些想快速賺錢的開發商，很多時候也會帶來資金和就業機會。當地政府這樣做，不怕短期內經濟發展會受影響嗎？
其實我覺得，他們的邏輯是想保護野澤溫泉獨特的文化和自然景觀。原文有提到，那裡吸引海外遊客是因為滑雪和溫泉。如果都蓋起一堆跟周遭格格不入的高樓大廈，那種獨特的魅力可能就消失了。
這樣說也對。如果所有滑雪勝地都長一樣，那大家去哪都沒差了。可是，這種「減法」策略真的能長期撐得住嗎？它有沒有辦法讓觀光收益維持，甚至更好？
這點我是信了，因為報導說他們希望吸引的是「有長期眼光的開發商」。這表示他們看中的不是單純的房間數量，而是更高品質、更能融入當地特色的體驗。這樣雖然飯店數量少，但可能單價高，而且更具品牌價值。
我好像有點理解了。如果我是個小店老闆，是不是也可以從這個案例學到，不要盲目追求擴大規模，而是專注把自己最核心、最獨特的價值做深做精？
沒錯。就像你開一家咖啡店，不一定要開分店開到處都是，而是把你的咖啡豆選得更好，手沖技術練得更棒，甚至打造一個很有故事感的空間。這樣客人會因為你的獨特而來，而不是因為你的便利性。
那一般上班族呢？這個概念怎麼帶入工作或生活？難道我要在每天的工作中「減少」什麼嗎？
嗯，我想到一件事。工作上，你可能每天都想把所有事情都做好，追求多工。但或許你可以試著，每天只專注在最關鍵的兩三件事上，把這些事做到最好，而不是讓自己被一堆瑣碎的事拖垮。
減少雜務、專注核心，有點像是把時間和精力投放在最有價值的地方。這樣效率可能更高，成果也更好。
對啊。或者生活上，你可能覺得要買很多東西才能滿足。但其實，是不是少一點東西，但每一件都是你真心喜歡、有品質的，反而更能帶來滿足感？這有點像是「少即是多」的商業智慧。
這樣聽起來，野澤溫泉的策略，好像也提醒了我們，有時候放慢腳步、選擇限制，反而能看清什麼是真正重要的，創造出更持久的價值。